في الاستوديو الفنانه الجميله الجاهده
وهبه جاهده اهلا بك يسعد صباحك شكرا
على المقدمه الجميله كمان اهلا وسهلا طيب
تقولين يا جاهده الموسيقى جوهري ونصف
الاخر حدثينا اكثر عن شغف جاهده بالموسيقى
او النغم يعني هيك خطفني بليله ما فيها
ضوء قمر وصرت انا
عاشقه النغم والفن وزوجته
[ضحك]
فيعني دايما النغم هو حياتي وبعتقد انه
كلنا مع الفنون الفنون تعطي لحياتنا بعد
اخر وهي بتساعدنا على يعني بظل كل اللي عم
نعيشه تاخذنا على مطرح اخصب وانقى واشهى
اين على موروثاتنا بسبب العولمه ما اكثر
ما يقلقك ويخيفك
الحقيقه انا بعتبر انه نحن كامم ضعيفه
نسبيا في ظل هذه العولمه اللي بلشت عم
تبلعنا فاذا لم نكن متنبهين الى موروثنا
الثقافي والحضاري وربما سعينا اكثر الى
ارشفته وادخاله في هذا البعد الرقمي فراح
يندثر تباعا خاصه وانه عم نحاول يعني انا
بشوف نحن فنانين دائما عنا هاجس التشبه
بالغرب او انه نستنسخ منه بدل ما نحن نصدر
له نحن عنا موروث وافر وغني جدا جدا جدا
فلماذا التشبه بالغرب وبالاخرين علينا نحن
نعطيهم الموروثنا علينا نحافظ نخلي هذه
صله الرحم للرباط موصول مع تراثنا قد ما
قدمنا يعني جديد ومعاصر ومعاصر ما لازم
ننسى هويتنا وثقافتنا هويتنا الحضاريه
كتير مهمه
طيب قبل ما نكمل كمان فقره الاسئله لانها
فقره فنجان قهوه القهوه
يعني انك تجيدين انماط موسيقيه عديده
حدثيني عن خيارتك الموسيقيه بين الشعر
والادب وكيف تختارين القصائد المغامرات
شوفي الحمد لله الله حباني بصوت ونعمه
يعني بعتبر انه
بقدر بصوتي اقدم عده انماط مثل ما ذكرتي
يعني انا قدمت في البدايه لبست عباءه
الطرب وبعدين بلشت فتش على النهج اللي انا
بدي ادمه الخاص فيا من خلال تلحين القصائد
ومن خلال تعرفي على الادب كمان رحت اكثر
ثوب الصوفي حبيت الصوفي اني اقدم الصوفي
بعدين الاوبرا قدمتي عمل اوبرالي ضخم جدا
وخاصه الدراسات سمحت بهالموضوع لاني درست
لغناء الشرقي ودرست ايضا الاوبرا باللغه
العربيه
ومؤخرا كان عنا مشروع جاز مهم جدا في
ابوظبي والهيك هلا انا موجوده معكم ساعه
وكثير سعيده
بعتقد انه الدراسات اللي قمت فيها وايضا
الفنان يعني هو من حال ويبلش يطلع من نفسه
الاطلاع على الانواع الموسيقيه وايضا
الغرف من المكتبه الادبيه فخلاه هل موهبه
تصير يعني شاسعه اكثر والحمد لله انه عم
بكون في شهادات موسوعه غنائيه لا ما بحب
اقول انا ممسوح شامل احب اني اعطي من
تجربتي لكن بحب اني راكبها وبعتبر انه كل
ما الانسان ضل يعتبر حاله انه هو بعده
جديد ومتدرب كل ما اشتغل على حاله طيب
الساده جاهزه لما احنا بنسمع كمان مثلا
تلاوه لقصائد حتى بلا شكسبير مثلا مش بس
يعني كمان لعرب وقدماء العرب اليوم ما
بتعتبري انه في جمهور معين احنا بنتوجه له
من خلال فنك جمهور النخبه فقط وهل هذا
بيسعدك ولا بيقلقك اليوم في ظل انه في
كمان جمهور جمهور كبير اوس يفضل امور اخرى
من الفن شوفي بالنهائي بالبدايه انا ما
فيي اقدم الا فن بشبهني اللي انا بحبه
وطبعا كل فنان عنده طموح انه رقعه
الجماهير عنده تكبر ما تكون فقط نخلويه
لكن انا لا اريد ان ازيف نفسي في سبيل ان
اكون مسوقه اكثر او موجوده عند نخب اكبر
لكن بعتبر انه نحن بطريقه ما قادرين نجيب
الجمهور لعندنا مش نروح على مقوله الجمهور
عايز كده وروح انا لعندهم لا فينا نلتقي
على نص الطريق يعني بقدم انا اللي حابه
اني اقدمه واللي بعتبر انه لازم قدمه لانه
يعني بظل اللي عم نعيشه فيه كتير غناء اذا
بدك عادي او يعني مثل الناس بتحبه بس انا
من خلال توزيع الموسيقى عم حاول من خلال
طرح الموسيقى عم حاول نجيب لعندي نخب
جديده جيب الشباب خاصه اللي بيعلنوني اللي
انا بعتبر انه ذائقتهم ربما يعني تهجزا او
تؤخذ الى امكنه امكنه اخرى بيعنيني انه
يضلوا متشبسين بتراسنا بهذه الثقافه
الموسيقيه هيدي
بحاول قدر الامكان من خلال القالب
الموسيقي اللي بدي قدمه الاطار اللي بدي
اقدمه يعني لا مؤخرا مثل ما ذكرنا انه
قدمنا بابو ظبي عملنا تذكرت الشيكسبير
عملنا الليله 352 اللي هو ماخوذ عن قصه من
قصص الف ليله وليله من خلال الشعر قدمناه
مع اوركسترا بروكسيل للجاز وبالحان الصديق
اسامه عبد الرسول
صياغه اتت من استاذ
استاذ حازم كمال دين وهو اخو اسامه عبد
الرسول من خلال قصائد اللي كان في شكسبير
وايضا المتنبي بدر شاكر سياب مظفر النواب
بولند الحيدري اعاد كتابه هذه القصه ولكن
قدمناها باسلوب الجاز فلقينا انه الجمهور
كان كثير متشوق ولم يكن فقط مثلا من محبي
جاز كان في من محبين
القصه من محبي الشاعر وهكذا توسعت رقعه
هذا الجمهور السيده جاهده قلتي مره احاول
ان اصل الى الروح واخاطب الوجدان من خلال
موسيقاي اليوم نحبك تخاطبي وجدان صباح
العربيه وتسمعينا شي
مسمعكم شو بدنا نسمعكم شو بتحبوا في شي
معين
بقول لكم مقطع من العمل اللي قدمناه ليله
30052 بالمجمع الثقافي من
جبران ايضا بالمحكيه بيت بالمحكيه مش
معروف كتير انه هو لجبران خليل جبران
بيقول
عيني
يموت
ما احلى
الوراء
بالواما
وما احلى
عايزه بيه
هو الله
يطوف النهر
وتحومي
ليل
وادي
وبعمل
زنودي
جاسرعيك
لا هيا
يلا تحول الواد تحاول يعني بس يطلع الضباب
فوق الوادي
العزوبيه ايوه
رح نسمع كمان وحده بس
اوكي طيب اذا في دقيقتين في عنا كمان
حابين هيك نشبع منك ونسمع كمان بدون اسئله
خلاص يعني بنغني شو بدنا نغني راح اغني
لكم مقطع من ايدياف بالفرنسيه والعربيه
كمان من عمل انا قدمته دي جاهزه ام كلثوم
لانه كمان انت حكيتوا عن ترجمه النصوص من
اللغات الاجنبيه الى العربيه
نو
ضر
التريا نيلوبياكم
[موسيقى]
ولا
شيء
لا ما بندم
عشير
كنسل الماضي
وارجعت حفياني
[موسيقى]
جمعه تغمار غمار وقت اتخطب للنار جرار
الضحك والاه
وحزننا اللي بالاسرار
بحياتها قصص الحب
نهدي الطريق
[موسيقى]
القلب رميت الزمان بعيد وراح
بلش من جديد
[موسيقى]
لا ولا شيء لا ما بندم على الشيء الى اخره
الله شكرا وبعدين دايما جهد وهبه معروفه
انه مش بحاجه المايكروفون وهذا شغله كثير
حلوه يعني هذه الموهبه اكيد طورتيها من
خلال تقنيات الصوت وهذه التميز اللي احنا
في عندنا ضيقه
كمان غناء
بسالك انه اليوم بتحسي انه دايما المسرح
اله هيبه اكثر من غناء الطاولات الطاولات
والعشوات يعني
ما فينا نعتبر انه بس هيبه انا بعتبر انه
المغني عنده رساله عم بقدمها فانا بحب اني
اقدم لناس كون كل مخيلتهم وكل ذاكرتهم وكل
تركيزهم وعيون معي ما بحب انه يكون يعني
هالوعي مشتت بين الاكل والراس
لاني بعتبر انه الف ن مقدس والغناء مقدس
لهيك ما رح يعني صوب الا الغناء لناس فقط
في المسارح وفي مهرجانات
مع احترامي يعني الكبير للفنانين اللي
بيغنوا يعني احيانا بالمطاعم لكن انا انا
برتاح اني كنت عم بغني لانسان يكون معي
بكل بكل حواس
بكل حواس شكرا معك بناء وكلاما شكرا شكرا
جزيلا لوجودك معنا شكرا